what are the the core principles to
becoming world class at Business
Development so for me you've got to want
to do it first of all right you've got
to want to pick up the phone you've got
to want to send those emails and again a
part of Business Development that goes
under the radar is actually getting the
clients on the phone and that's got a
lot harder so I think nowadays you've
got to have a great personal brand
there's a lot of people I see posting on
LinkedIn and it's something we're
working on here at metric but making
those cold calls slightly warm for me is
massive now when they're seeing you
content you're engaging with them on
LinkedIn and socials that is at least
going to help you get your foot in the
door obviously when you get on the phone
with them impressing them is a
completely different matter but it's
being candidate LED and it's not being
afraid of that it's got so competitive
recently right that these recruiters are
talking to clients all the time like
you've got to have a good candidate to
back up what you're saying it's all well
and good me going on the call and saying
look I'm the number one recruiter in the
cdmo space this is my track record
generally they just want to see a great
candidate they want to see a solution